so dyslexia has an unexplained
difficulty in learning to read and by
unexplained we mean it's not because
your vision is poor or your hearing is
poor but you seem to have all the
capacities you need to become a good
reader but you don't and you struggle as
a child it's estimated to affect about
10 percent of us children so one in ten
so every classroom will have one or two
children who will really struggle to
learn to read so brain imaging studies
in the past have found differences in
poor readers both in brain structure and
function but we didn't know those brain
differences were due the consequence of
poor reading or the cause of full
reading in the study in the journal of
neuroscience we wanted to address this
question and the way we did it is we did
brain imaging with kindergarteners
we were seeing these kindergarteners
before they had explicit reading
instruction in their school elizabeth
norton is a postdoctoral fellow and she
organized much of the recruiting and
screening and brain imaging of the
children as part of this study we work
with 25 schools in massachusetts and
rhode island
charter schools catholic schools public
schools a whole range of different types
of classrooms in different areas so
previous studies in adults and older
children have shown that certain white
matter pathways in the brain and one in
particular the arcuate fasciculus is
smaller and less well organized in
people who have dyslexia so we set out
to find out in children who were just
beginning kindergarten if this area was
already smaller and less well organized
when a child enrolls in this
longitudinal part of the study with us
they come for the first visit to mit
where we do eeg and behavioral
assessment and then they come for a
second visit for mri within a few weeks
later
the behavioral assessments that we do
with the children
cover three main areas and when we work
with children we set them up as games
and the one game or task that we found
was really related to
the brain in this study is called
phoneme blending so we would say to the
child i'm going to play you a series of
sounds over your headphones and you're
going to listen to these recorded sounds
and blend them together to make a word
so if over their headphones they heard
um at they would blend it together and
the right answer would be matt
they spend about 45 minutes in the mri
for us to take a few different types of
scans and do a couple of functional
tasks and actually the last one we do is
this diffusion weighted scan that we're
looking at in this paper
my colleague zanet sagan analyzed these
diffusion weighted imaging measures
what we're looking at here with the
fusion weight imaging is long-range
connectivity so the pathways of the
brain that connect regions to one
another axons which are
what allows the neuron to communicate
with another neuron are myelinated with
a fatty sheath and so this makes water
diffuse in one particular orientation
and so we can compute that for every
small area of the brain and we can sort
of connect the lines to create what we
see as tractographic images like this
one so what we found was that children
with a smaller arcuate fasciculus
the lower their awareness of how
phonemes blend together to form a word
and we found that
not only the volume but the organization
of the y minor tracks and we can
actually see it here so these are
four subjects and we can see just the
mere size of the arcuate it's very
different in a child whose score is zero
on the blending words test versus 11 on
the blending words test
so we could see these brain differences
present before reading instruction which
strongly suggests that they're part of
the problem that a child faces learning
to read or part of the cause of poor
reading rather than a consequence of
lack of reading practice
the next step is exactly longitudinally
following those same children we're
following these and several years of
children to see whether we can predict
accurately which child will succeed and
which will fail a reading we understand
uh dyslexia as a consequence of a brain
organization that is not optimal for
reading
and so if we can figure out what how to
measure those effectively you know we
can identify those children for whom
intensive immediate intervention might
make a big difference in their lives
you